[Music]
on this thursday night
essential unprotected from covid and at
risk
frustrated workers on the front lines
still waiting for their shot
the pandemic's not going to take a
holiday the mounting pressure to speed
up canada's vaccine rollout
too strict or too lacks the growing
anger from both sides over alberta's new
restrictions
violence erupts in northern ireland
immediately what's fueling flaring
tempers and rising tensions
and dance of joy
why canada's famous bhangra sensation
has a new reason to celebrate
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
bara nasser good evening and thanks for
joining us glad to be with you tonight
we're going to begin with what most
people are feeling right now
frustration multiple provinces are
facing a major resurgence of covid19
there are questions about how we even
got here and canadians at the end of
their rope are now being told how
important it is to
once again stay home in hot zones all of
this
while we wonder if we're really
vaccinating as many people as possible
so far roughly 6.4 million canadians
have received at least one dose
that's about 16.9 percent of the
population
millions of canadians are still waiting
in line and of course with the variance
in the mix
case counts are accelerating fast over
the last week
more than 6500 people tested positive
on average per day the number of
confirmed variant cases has surged
past 16 000. now we've been saying it
for a year
frontline workers of all kinds have been
heroes this pandemic and if you want to
talk about frustration
imagine being one of them many not
qualifying yet for the vaccine
yet putting themselves at risk going to
work some in
high risk areas and then hearing of
vaccines
in freezers david aiken has tonight's
top story
in some busy grocery stores a worker
could be exposed to
a thousand strangers every day reason
for concern
reason workers want a vaccine asap
the worry of course is quite high you
know knowing that these variants
especially would affect my age group in
a more detrimental way
nathan leblanc forte a cashier is booked
to get his first
jab in may but he's worried what might
happen until then
it's still frustrating because we know
that
the pandemic's not going to take a
holiday there's still 30 possible days
of you know maybe coming into contact
with someone with
a positive case lots of people are doing
essential work to feed and care for
canadians
a doula for example helps women in their
home
before during and after pregnancy
without a vaccine
doula griselda hernandez wonders if she
can continue to serve families
safely sometimes you you kind of just
start thinking well
should i should i keep supporting these
people in need or should i just
step aside and and just stay at home
there is no quick fix and it can be
frustrating for many because
on any given day canada has hundreds of
thousands of vaccines in freezers
not in arms but that experts say
is how it has to work when the first
vaccines arrived in canada on december
13th
all of the doses 100 percent went into
the freezer
but then vaccination programs ramped up
and for the last several weeks on any
given day
about 25 of all doses are in a freezer
it's a buffer that lets provinces manage
their own vaccine programs
but in the last month that buffer has
edged up on monday
35 were in a freezer that's a high not
seen since the middle of january
on mondays we have a very regular
delivery schedule with pfizer
and on mondays you will see a spike in
numbers
in other words that's normal but there
is room for improvement
i think it's fair to say that yeah of
course we should be picking up the pace
of vaccination
but in the same breath you have to have
some reserve
in the freezer picking up the pace will
be up to each province
the federal government is reluctant to
step on provincial toes
when it comes to vaccine delivery or
priority lists
it is up to health authorities in the
provinces and territories
to decide how best to apply it in their
immunization programs
david aiken global news ottawa
still with frontline workers a mass
vaccination clinic is being set up at
the cargill meat packing plant
in high river alberta that is the site
of canada's largest outbreak last year
two employees died nearly half of the
2200 workers
contracted covet 19. the immunizations
are part of a pilot program
and will be administered by the
company's own team of nurses
there are hopes the pilot could expand
to other meat processing plants
vulnerable because of tight working
conditions and cultural barriers
the workers are part of alberta's next
phase of vaccine rollout expected to
begin
in a couple weeks and it cannot come
soon enough
alberta now has the most cases per
capita in the country
more than twelve thousand people are
infected with the virus
a forty one percent increase in just one
week
many doctors say new restrictions won't
be enough
to flatten the curve but premier jason
kenney is facing a revolt
from members within his own party
critical of his latest public health
measures
there is anger and there is frustration
on all sides
and as heather ux west explains the
premier may only have
himself to blame if you try to fight a
middle ground on the highway and stand
there
you tend to get run over as alberta's
third wave
builds premier jason kenney is facing
opposition from all
sides if we don't institute more
strict public health measures that
inevitably the health system
will be overwhelmed what albertans
particularly you know in cyprus medicine
hat are asking for is
is more freedom while doctors groups say
the province's new restrictions
won't be enough to bend the curve more
than a quarter of kenny's caucus believe
the measures go too far i respect their
responsibility as elected
representatives to
to articulate concerns like that
but at the end of the day the government
must decide
uh how best to protect lives and the
health care system
still the premier says he expects his
members to respect public health orders
and
encourage constituents to do the same
anyone that does not
will be kicked out of caucus but the
mixed messages from elected officials
are having an impact we have the numbers
we are united and we are not closing
on tuesday the owner of a calgary boxing
gym took to social media to make his
intentions known
while the grace life church outside
edmonton has been defying orders for
months
it wasn't until this week that the rcmp
moved in to erect barricades
to shut the church down the fact that
we've got people in positions of
leadership people who are elected
officials
uh making claims that you know the the
rules are too stringent
is entirely unhelpful but over the past
year the premier's own messages have
been inconsistent
too a week ago the premier was singing a
very different tune they were willing to
tolerate
some rise in the hospitals some rise in
the
case numbers thinking that they wouldn't
go up high enough to threaten the
hospital
these variants the virus may have forced
the government to change
course but many albertans don't appear
to be following along
heather urex west global news calgary
quebec is tightening restrictions to try
to counter rising cases and fast
spreading variants
emergency measures have been extended in
three regions including quebec city and
start this sunday
the curfew in montreal and laval will
shift back to 8 pm
the virus is present everywhere and the
variant
is more contagious i ask you to reduce
your contacts as much
as possible i know it's difficult
but it's the only way to stop this
third wave and one of quebec's most
worrying hot spots
is the quebec city region it's dealing
with a major spike
linked to new variants and one case in
particular
is a perfect example of the exponential
growth experts keep telling us about
amanda jeliwicki reports on an outbreak
at a gym
that led to more than 400 cases
quebec city's mega fitness gym reopened
early last month
after months of pressure from outspoken
owner and co-wood critic
dan marino while many are now blaming
his gym for a staggering covert outbreak
in the quebec city region
i think it really unfortunately serves
as a
serious warning sign to how quickly
things can spiral out of control with
these easily transmissible variants
the gym reopened on march 8th after
closing in october
on march 26 public health linked a few
cases to it
officials closed the gym march 31st
blaming the owner for ignoring sanitary
measures
204 people have caught kova directly
from the gym
another 236 indirectly it's caused
38 outbreaks in the region since march
23rd
quebec has seen an 850 increase in
covert cases
all it takes is a few people to do a few
things and
a few super spreader events and all of a
sudden you have exponential growth
the family of etienne de gaulle jean
claimed he contracted covet at the gym
the 40 year old died from the virus this
week the first
feeling you get here you say my god i'm
lucky because
i i got through it a bit easily
dominique liliev didn't know de roshan
despite respecting rules
he also contracted kovit from the mega
gym
most people in quebec city only think
about the gym and blame the gym for
schools or closing when you say that you
are a customer of this gym and you kind
of
people don't like you very much the
quebec city outbreak is the worst the
area has seen since the pandemic began
experts say loosening restrictions too
soon can cause problems
it's a fair statement that all these
preventative measures work a lot better
if you put them in place before you have
large transmission
now the fear is what's happening in
quebec city could also hit
other regions of the province amanda
jalawiki
global news montreal
in bc health officials are changing the
way they test for covid 19 variants
so our strategy moving forward
given this high rate of transmission or
high rate of
vocs that we're seeing in in british
columbia
will be to no longer routinely sequence
for confirmation
we just assume that that those
screen positives will be the variants
the province says that variants
especially the one first detected in the
united kingdom
are driving new case numbers in the past
24 hours
1293 new covid 19 cases were detected in
bc
that is the highest number of daily
cases in the province
since the pandemic began
in ontario an expert group of scientists
advising the province on the pandemic
is recommending that doctors ration
doses of a drug used to treat covid19
patients
because of supply shortages now the move
comes as ontario hospitals face
a record number of coveted patients
fighting for their lives in the icu
and other provinces are in a similar
dire situation eric sorensen reports on
the side effects
of this drug decision it is a shortage
we don't hear as much about
as intensive care units fill up
straining hospital capacity for beds and
ventilators
there is something else here that saves
lives that is in short supply
a drug called tosul izumab along with
the workhorse steroid dexamethasone
the drug treats patients whose immune
systems cause inflammation in the lungs
that can be life-threatening and doctors
have seen it work wonders
people that i previously saw would
rapidly progress to requiring a
mechanical ventilator
or high-dose oxygen will kind of almost
level off
and then suddenly a couple of days later
they're better
which i found remarkable one fixed dose
of tosal izumab can be up to 800
milligrams
but ontario's covet 19 advisory science
table now recommends in light of ongoing
drug shortages a fixed dose of 400
milligrams should be used for all
eligible patients
and no follow-up a second dose should
not be given to any patient because of
shortages
one smaller dose is deemed effective but
the problem is there are too few doses
available in some ontario hospitals
everyone around the world who's seen
covid
wants access to this drug it's you know
potentially life-saving
the challenge that we have here is
there's really just
insufficient supply the drug also known
as actemra
is produced under patent by one
manufacturer hoffman laroche
ottawa has secured a supply but with
high demand
health canada says it is working on
shortages of therapeutics with all the
parties involved the health canada
public health
agency uh looking at the clinical
experts so we're looking at the ways to
to to address that situation by our
estimations for every 25
patients who receives this drug one more
patient will be alive
who wouldn't otherwise be alive the drug
is already prescribed for rheumatoid
arthritis and doctors say any
redistribution cannot come at the
expense of patients who already use the
drug
it's difficult to manufacture quickly
and uh you know we do really want to
make sure that we're not
taking it away from somebody else who
really needs it tosul izumab is not seen
as a magic bullet
but as serious covet cases climb in icus
doctors say they will need more of it
eric sorensen global news toronto
northern ireland is calling for calm
tonight
coming up what's ignited days of riots
and unrest
days of unrest in parts of northern
ireland where tonight's police
are out in force and what some are
calling the worst
violence in years politicians of all
stripes are calling for calm but as
crystal gomencing explains
there's concern the situation could
escalate even
more a smoldering bus
igniting past pains and flaring current
frustrations
we must stand united and appealing to
all concerned
to refrain from further threats or use
of violence
the violence in northern ireland is
floating on top of historic simmering
political tensions
and new ones caused in part by brexit
in keeping with the 1998 good friday
agreement that
mostly ended the deadly violence of the
troubles
there's no border between the republic
of ireland and northern ireland
ireland is still in the eu northern
ireland
is not but with brexit came a protocol
leaving northern ireland in the eu's
market for goods
so there are checks and import rules on
products arriving from britain
that frustrates uk loyalists living in
northern
ireland what we're seeing with the
violence specifically being
you know located at the peace walls and
directed at the peacefuls
appears to be a narrative where these
people are saying
the peace is broken the belfast
agreement
or good friday agreement promised no
borders
authorities say criminal organizations
and militias
are exploiting young people and using
them to destabilize the community
more than 50 officers have been injured
as demonstrations have escalated over
the past several days
to riots and no brick
no bottle no petrol bomb thrown has
achieved or can ever achieve
anything but destruction harm and fear
power in northern ireland is shared
between those who support
being a part of the united kingdom and
those who want a united ireland
they've jointly called for calm but it's
unclear if
they'll be able to avoid being pulled
into the street fight
crystal gomanson global news london
in the u.s some long-awaited action
aimed at curbing that country's deadly
gun violence
gun violence in this country is an
epidemic and
it's an international embarrassment
president joe biden has announced
new gun control measures after the mass
shootings in georgia and colorado
a series of executive actions direct the
justice department to
restrict weapons known as ghost guns
they're largely homemade without serial
numbers
restrict stabilizing braces that turn
pistols into rifles
resume firearms tracking that stopped
more than 20 years ago
and draft red flag laws allowing
relatives and police to ask a judge
to keep weapons from people who pose a
danger to themselves or others
still ahead the tool that could tackle
future pandemics
[Music]
as vaccination campaigns ramp up there
was also a push to create a vaccine
that would provide protection from all
coronaviruses
covet 19 is the third major outbreak of
a coronavirus in the past
two decades and as michael couture
reports researchers say we need to be
ready
for the next one it's not your ordinary
covid19 vaccine
this shot developed at the walter reed
army institute of research
is entering phase one of clinical trials
but the lead researcher believes
it could be the basis for a universal
coronavirus vaccine
not just the different variants the
different strains but potentially
other coronaviruses
in that same family tree it's one of
many efforts across the globe to develop
one vaccine that will protect people
against all strains of coronavirus
even those that haven't crossed to
humans yet
canadian researchers are also working on
one led by dr volker gertz
at the university of saskatchewan the
whole idea is
having vaccines before a new disease
even emerges
would save you all these millions of
lives some that you lose during that
year and the trillions and dollars
i mean economic classes the idea isn't
new
following sars in 2003 maria elena
bottasi
at the baylor college of medicine
started working on a pan coronavirus
vaccine
but funding dried up in 2016 as the
focus turned to other viruses
like ebola and zika i think
there was a little bit of a loss of
memory
that coronaviruses could could return
bad that they return so quickly covet 19
is the third major outbreak of a
coronavirus in the last two decades
this latest one has a lower mortality
rate compared to sars in 2003
and mers in 2012. wayne cough of the
human vaccines project believes
now is the time for collaboration to
create
a universal coronavirus vaccine we've
never had tools like we have now in
terms of artificial intelligence and
machine and machine learning so it
simply is not it's not
just a biology problem artificial
intelligence is what helped map the
genomic sequence
of the sars cov2 strain researchers say
it'll take a cross-disciplinary and
multilateral effort
to find the achilles heel of all
coronaviruses
so that they might be able to develop a
vaccine it will also take
time money and political will however
researchers believe
it's worth putting in the effort now
before the next pandemic hits
mike liquiter global news ottawa
next we're going to tell you the reason
for this celebratory bungara
a canadian man turned internet sensation
and international inspiration is sending
the world more
positive vibes gurdy pander received his
second shot of the covet 19 vaccine
and his latest viral video has a
powerful message
it's important to take care of each
other it's important to stand for each
other
and and please please go and get your
vaccine
throughout the pandemic he's been
spreading the love with his daily dances
and has built a massive following from
his cabin
in the far north thank you greedy for
putting a smile on our faces
that is global national for this
thursday night i'm farah nasser it's
been a pleasure to be with you
tonight your canada is the sunrise over
point claire quebec
thank you so much for watching robin
gill is going to be with you tomorrow
until next time
take care of yourselves and each other
good night